I know I know I know why you're excited
today huh boy March Came In Like a Lion
and went out with Trump on the lamb
wow
I know that's a that's the first in
American history you realize that no
American former president has ever
uh I and this is course for the payment
to Stormy Daniels to keep her mouth shut
and uh I I we could get bogged down in
the legal details of this just suffice
it to say if you don't know all about
the details here that um Trump's lawyer
went to jail for this
I mean
it's like getting the clap and your
doctor dies I mean
so uh Trump will uh surrender next week
in court in New York and uh
they say it'll probably go right home
they say he's not a Flight Risk Flight
Risk you can't get up a ramp
uh but yeah he's gonna
surrender on Tuesday who will be
arrested he will be fingerprinted and
everybody at MSNBC is actually the same
question is it wrong to jerk off to a
mug shot
and
find it
I thought it's so funny that the guy the
the D.A in New York who brought this
case Alvin Bragg I love this that the
most boastful man ever in history is
indicted by a guy named Bragg
[Applause]
it would be like if the prosecutor in
the R Kelly case was named Dave tinkle
and boy Trump is pissed and I don't
blame him you know he's spent his whole
life stiffing people and the one time he
pays someone
this happens
ah boy
no of course he knows the potential for
violence so he's calling for calm I'm
joking of course he's
rousing up his riotous MOBA goons to do
whatever they're going to do and so the
the authorities are keeping eye on Trump
supporters now because they're worried
about this they're they're monitoring
social media right-wing websites and the
smoking section at the Waffle House
[Applause]
and of course all the Republicans are
incensed Lauren bobert said this is not
the America that she would have her
illitimate illegitimate children raise
their election with children in uh
Lindsey Graham said I don't want daddy
going to prison
retailer green was at a complete lost
for words so no change there
no
no I'm kidding Marjorie Taylor green she
actually tweeted out she said we must
protest this unconstitutional Witch Hunt
she said and then she said I'm going to
New York Tuesday
okay okay Marjorie we'll see you next
Tuesday
oh